MORE IN OUR OPENING
MONOLOGUE BREAKING NEWS
MONOLOGUE TONIGHT.
♪
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, A TON OF
I PROMISE WOULD WILL GET IT
ALL IN.
IT'S A LOT.
WE START WITH THIS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SLAMMING
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS FOR RELYING ON AN
OBAMA APPOINTED, INSPECTOR
GENERAL TO PROBE THE MASSIVE
FISA ABUSE SCANDAL AND NOT
DOJ LAWYERS WHO ACTUALLY
HAVE REAL PROSECUTORIAL
POWER.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED
EARLIER TODAY QUOTE WHY IS
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS ASKING THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL TO
INVESTIGATE POTENTIALLY
MASSIVE FISA ABUSE?
WELL, WILL TAKE FOREVER, HAS
NO PROSECUTORIAL POWER AND
ALREADY LATE WITH REPORTS ON
COMEY, ET CETERA.
ISN'T THE IG AN OBAMA GUY?
WHY NOT USE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT LAWYERS AND HE
WRITES DISGRACEFUL.
THEN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
WELL, HE RESPONDED.
HE PUT OUT A STATEMENT IT
READS, QUOTE:  WE HAVE
INITIATED THE APPROPRIATE
PROCESS THAT WILL ENSURE
COMPLAINTS AGAINST THIS
DEPARTMENT WILL BE FULLY AND
FAIRLY ACTED UPON IF
NECESSARY.
AS LONG AS I'M THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, I WILL CONTINUE TO
DISCHARGE MY DUTIES WITH
INTEGRITY AND HONOR AND THIS
DEPARTMENT WILL CONTINUE TO
DO ITS WORK IN A FAIR AND
IMPARTIAL MANNER, ACCORDING
TO THE LAW AND THE
CONSTITUTION.
IN THIS CASE, I BELIEVE THE
PRESIDENT IS RIGHT.
NOW, WE KNOW FROM TWO
REPUBLICAN MEMOS AND THE
SCHIFF MEMO, THE DEMOCRATIC
MEMO, THAT THE CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DOSSIER
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT LIES AND PROP
BEGAN DA WAS USED TO SPY ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
WE KNOW THAT.
WE ALSO KNOW FOR A FACT THE
FBI AND DOJ LIED TO A FISA
JUDGE ABOUT CLINTON AND THE
DNC FINANCING THE DOSSIER.
AND THESE MEMOS SHOW US THAT
THIS FISA APPLICATION, IT
NEVER MENTIONED HILLARY OR
THE DNC THAT SHE CONTROLLED.
THEY NEVER TOLD THE FISA
JUDGES.
THAT IS CALLED MALICIOUSLY
LYING AND PURPOSEFULLY
DECEIVING FISA COURT JUDGES.
AND JUSTICES.
AND HERE IS WHAT IS WORSE.
THE FBI AND THE DOJ THEY DID
IT FOUR SEPARATE TIMES.
ONE FOR THE ORIGINAL WARRANT
TO SPY ON CARTER PAGE AND
THEN THAT WARRANT WAS
RENEWED ON THREE SEPARATE
OCCASIONS.
NOW, WE HAVE ALSO DISCOVERED
THAT, YES, THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN WAS, IN FACT, SPIED
ON AND HERE IS WHY.
WHEN THE FBI GOT APPROVAL
FOR THAT FISA WARRANT, USING
HER BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
DOSSIER, IT ALSO GAVE THEM
ACCESS TO EVERY ONE OF
CARTER PAGE'S OLD EMAILS.
THAT MEANS OLD TEXT
MESSAGES.
THAT MEANS OLD PHONE CALLS.
EVERYTHING WHICH DATES BACK
TO WHEN HE WAS A MEMBER OF
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
AND THEN IT GETS WORSE.
REMEMBER, POLITICO REPORTED
THAT THE FORMER TOP WHITE
HOUSE ADVISOR STEVE BANNON,
HE MAY HAVE EVEN BEEN PICKED
UP ON FBI SURVEILLANCE OF
PAGE.
NOW, THIS IS ABOUT IMMEDIATE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THIS IS ABOUT THE RULE OF
LAW.
IF YOU DID THIS AT HOME, I
PROMISE YOU WOULD BE
INVESTIGATED AND PROBABLY BE
ON TRIAL BY NOW.
AND GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS IN
THE END, I PREDICT ARE GOING
TO GO TO JAIL OVER THIS.
SO, IT IS TIME, KNOWING THE
FACTS AS WE HAVE THEM, WHICH
ARE INCONTRAVERTABLE AND
OVERWHELMING THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS TO DO
HIS JOB.
SERVE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
AND, YES, THE RULE OF LAW
AND THE CONSTITUTION.
AND JEFF SESSIONS, IF HE IS
NOT UP TO THE TASK, IF HE
WANTS TO CREATE A TWO TIERED
JUSTICE SYSTEM, WELL, WE
HAVE OTHER OPTIONS.
HOW ABOUT JUST A POINT
HOW ABOUT JUST APPOINT
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THAT'S OTHER BREAKING NEWS
TONIGHT.
ALL BRAND NEW REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN THEY ARE
DEMANDING THAT JEFF SESSIONS
DO THAT VERY THING.
APPOINT A SPECIAL COUNSEL TO
INVESTIGATE WHAT IS MASSIVE
AND WIDENING FISA ABUSE
SCANDALS.
THESE LAWMAKERS ALSO WANT
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL TO PROBE
THE CORRUPT CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION.
REMEMBER THE FIX WAS IN?
WRITING THE EXONERATION
BEFORE INVESTIGATION AND HOW
THE TRUMP-RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION EVEN STARTED.
NOW, WE JUST EXPLAINED ALL
THE KEY DETAILS ABOUT OBAMA
ERA FISA ABUSES.
NOW, HERE IS WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT THE SO-CALLED CLINTON
EMAIL INVESTIGATION.
WE KNOW THE FIX WAS IN FROM
THE BEGINNING.
WE KNOW IT WAS
PREDETERMINED, HILLARY WAS
NOT GOING TO BE CHARGED.
EVEN THOSE THAT SHE HAD ON
HER EMAIL SERVER WHICH WAS
UNSECURE AND A MOM AND POP
BATHROOM CLOSET.
AND SHE DELETED EMAILS ACID
WASHED, SMASHING BLACK
ENTERS
BLTERS
BLACRS
BLACKBERRIES WITH A HAMMER.
THEY WOULD SEND EVERY ONE OF
YOU TO JAIL OUT THERE.
EVERYONE OF COURSE NOT NAMED
HILLARY CLINTON FOR A LONG
TIME.
IT NEVER HAPPENED.
WHY NOT?
NOW, JAMES COMEY, TRUMP
HATING FBI AGENT PETER
STRZOK, OTHER TOP FBI
OFFICIALS, THEY STARTED
WRITING THE EXONERATION,
GAVE HER THE GET OUT OF JAIL
FREE CARD BEFORE DOING THEIR
INVESTIGATIVE WORK.
THEN THERE IS, OF COURSE,
THE ISSUE OF HOW THE
TRUMP-RUSSIA PROBE STARTED.
HERE IS THE INFORMATION WE
CURRENTLY HAVE.
THE TRUMP HATING FBI AGENT
PETER STRZOK WHO WAS A TOP
COUNTER INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIAL SIGNED THE
PAPERWORK THAT ACTUALLY
KICKED OFF THIS ENTIRE
RUSSIA WITCH-HUNT.
STRZOK, HIS FBI GIRLFRIEND,
MISTRESS AND LISA PAGE, THEY
ARE AS CORRUPT AS THEY COME.
THEY TALKED ABOUT AN
INSURANCE POLICY WITH WHO WE
THINK IS THE FORMER FBI
DEPUTY DIRECTOR ANDREW
MCCABE.
REMEMBER THAT?
INSURANCE POLICY.
INSURANCE POLICY IN CASE OF
WHAT?
DONALD TRUMP WINNING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE DECIDING
THEY WANT HIM AS THEIR
PRESIDENT?
WE ALSO HAVE NEW AT THIS
HOUR HILLARY CLINTON HAS
ZERO SHAME.
SHE IS ACTUALLY PRETENDING
TONIGHT TO BE OUTRAGED.
SHE IS FAINING OUTRAGE AND
ACCUSING PRESIDENT TRUMP OF
SURRENDERING TO THE
RUSSIANS.
SHE LASHED OUT EARLIER TODAY
IN A TWEET WRITING QUOTE I
SAY THIS AS A FORMER
SECRETARY OF STATE AND AS AN
AMERICAN, THE RUSSIANS ARE
STILL COMING.
OUR INTELLIGENCE
PROFESSIONALS ARE IMPLORING
TRUMP TO ACT HAD HE CONTINUE
TO IGNORE AND SURRENDER OR
PROTECT OUR COUNTRY.
HILLARY, YOU COULDN'T BE A
BIGGER HYPOCRITE OR MORE
PARTISAN HACK.
DO YOU REALLY HAVE THE
AUDACITY TO LECTURE ANYBODY
ON RUSSIA?
DID YOU FORGET THAT
DID YOU FORGET YHAT
DID YOU FORGET YOUT
RESET BUTTON THAT YOU HANDED
OVER TO YOUR COUNTERPART OR
URANIUM ONE?
GIVING 20% OF AMERICA'S
URANIUM TO THE HOSTILE
REGIME OF RUSSIA, THE
HOSTILE ACTOR VLADIMIR
PUTIN?
OR MAYBE IT WAS BECAUSE YOU
AND BILL, OH, LET'S SEE YOU
DOUBLED HIS SPEAKING FEES IN
MOSCOW?
AND THEN $145 MILLION
FLOWING RIGHT BACK INTO YOUR
FOUNDATION, THE PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THAT DEAL?
OR ABOUT HOW YOU SUPPORTED
BARACK OBAMA AND DID
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING, EVEN
THOUGH HE WAS WARNED AGAIN
AND AGAIN THAT HE HAD TO
STOP RUSSIA ELECTION
INTERFERENCE?
OH, AND HILLARY, THERE IS
ALSO THE DOSSIER.
AND THE EVIDENCE OF REAL
RUSSIA COLLUSION IN THE
CAMPAIGN OF 2016.
AND HOW YOU AND THE DNC THAT
YOU CONTROLLED FORKED OVER
OVER $12 MILLION FOR RUSSIAN
LIES TO LIE TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ON THE -- ABOUT TO GO
INTO THE BALLOT BOX ON THE
EVE OF AN ELECTION.
REALLY?
JUST A LITTLE BIT OF FREE
ADVICE, HILLARY, WHEN IT
COMES TO RUSSIA, MAYBE YOU
JUST WANT TO KEEP YOUR RIGHT
TO REMAIN SILENT.
AND ALSO TONIGHT.
WE HAVE EVEN MORE BREAKING
NEWS.
IT INVOLVES A VERY BIG
QUESTION AND HERE IT IS.
OKAY.
HOW DO FOUR FISA JUDGES THAT
WE NOW KNOW TONIGHT WERE
LIED TO, BY THE FBI.
AS IT RELATES TO THE CLINTON
DOSSIER, HOW DO THESE JUDGES
FEEL ABOUT BEING LIED TO?
WELL, TONIGHT, WE HAVE NEW
INFORMATION TO HELP ANSWER
THAT VERY QUESTION.
SARA CARTER REPORTING THAT
FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE
SURVEILLANCE COURT PRESIDING
JUDGE HER NAME IS ROSEMARY
COLLIER, SHE TOLD
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES AND
CONGRESSMAN BOB GOODLATTE IN
A FEBRUARY 18TH LETTER THAT
DOCUMENTS THEY ARE
REQUESTING FROM THE FISA
COURT CAN ACTUALLY OBTAINED
FROM THE DOJ WITH THE
APPROVAL FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE.
NOW, IN HER LETTER, THIS IS
WHERE IT GETS INTERESTING,
SHE WRITES THAT REQUESTS FOR
FISA COURT INFORMATION
RELATED TO THE APPROVAL OF A
FISA WARRANT TO SPY ON
CARTER PAGE, QUOTE, PRESENT
NOVEL AND SIGNIFICANT
QUESTIONS NOFLT NEVER
HAPPENING BEFORE AND
SIGNIFICANT PRETTY PROFOUND.
THE JUDGE SAYS IT DOESN'T
HAVE ANY PROBLEM WITH THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH RELEASING
ANY MATERIAL FROM THE FISA
COURT TO CONGRESS.
HERE'S MY TAKE AWAY.
SOUNDS LIKE THIS ONE JUDGE
AND PROBABLY THE OTHER THREE
ARE NOW SAYING WE KNOW
PRETTY DARN WELL WE WERE
LIED TO.
WE WERE MANIPULATED BUT WE
HAVE TO NOW GO THROUGH THE
PROPER PROCESS TO GET THE
TRUTH OUT.
THAT IS A MAJOR DEVELOPMENT.
WE'LL BE FOLLOWING THIS
STORY VERY, VERY CLOSELY.
ALSO BRAND NEW TONIGHT, THAT
CLOCK IS TICKING FOR THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION, THOSE
OFFICIALS TO ANSWER
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES' 10
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE DOSSIER.
THE DEADLINE FOR THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE, THE
CHAIRMAN SAID IS FRIDAY AT
MIDNIGHT.
WHAT DEVIN NUNES IS TRYING
TO FIND OUT IS WHAT THESE
OBAMA OFFICIALS KNEW, WHEN
DID THEY KNOW IT IN REGARDS
TO THIS PHONY DOSSIER.
WE KNOW THE OBAMA FBI, DOJ,
STATE DEPARTMENT, MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS, ALL EITHER HAD THE
DOSSIER OR WERE BRIEFED ON
THIS PHONY DOSSIER.
WHAT NUNES RIGHTLY IS
SEEKING ARE ANSWERS TO HOW
THESE OFFICIALS FOUND OUT
ABOUT THE DOSSIER.
WHO TOLD THEM ABOUT IT, AND
THEN WHAT THEY DID WITH THAT
INFORMATION.
NOW, THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL," THEIR EDITORIAL
BOARD, THEY ARE RAISING SOME
VERY IMPORTANT, SERIOUS
QUESTIONS.
AND MAKING KEY POINTS ABOUT
THE DOSSIER.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE EDITORIAL
BOARD POINTS OUT THAT IF
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE DNC,
THEY ARE PAYING THE
12 MILLION BUCKS FOR THE
DOSSIER, WITH RUSSIAN
SOURCED LIES.
AND FUSION GPS WOULD HAVE
ALMOST CERTAINLY SHOWN THEM
WHAT THEIR MONEY BOUGHT.
NOW, FORMER SENATE MINORITY
LEADER HARRY REID ALSO
REFERENCED WHAT WAS IN THE
DOSSIER.
REMEMBER THIS POINT?
HE SENT THAT LETTER TO JAMES
COMEY AT THE END OF
OCTOBER 2016.
THIS WAS ONLY DAYS BEFORE
THE ELECTION.
CLEARLY THE DOSSIER WAS NOT
SOME CLOSELY HELD SECRET.
IN TERMS OF OFFICIALS ALL
ACROSS THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION OBVIOUSLY
KNEW ABOUT IT HARRY REID
KNEW ABOUT IT.
SO, IT'S NOW TIME FOR ALL OF
THEM TO RESPOND AND TELL US,
YOU, WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WHAT DID THEY KNOW AND WHEN
DID THEY KNOW IT?
THIS DOSSIER SCANDAL
STRETCHES WELL OUTSIDE OF
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND
20 MONTHS AFTER CHRISTOPHER
STEELE GAVE THIS PHONY, FAKE
NEWS DOSSIER TO THE FBI,
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, WE NOW
HAVE EVIDENCE THAT SO MANY
LIBERALS, TWO YEARS LATER,
ARE STILL TRYING TO PROVE
ITS TRUE.
RUSSIAN, HOOKERS, RITZ
CARLTON, MOSCOW URINATING ON
BED.
THEY ARE THAT DESPERATE.
"THE WASHINGTON TIMES" HAS
PUT TOGETHER A FULL LIST.
SCARBOROUGH OF ALL THE
LIBERAL PLAYERS IN THIS
SCANDAL THAT ARE ACTUALLY
HOPING THEY CAN VERIFY
ANYTHING IN THIS CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DOSSIER.
HERE IS A COUPLE EXAMPLES.
BUZZFEED REMEMBER THEY
PUBLISHED THE DOES
PUBLISHED THE DOSSIER THEY
ARE BEING SUED FOR LIBEL
THEY ARE HIRING CYBER
EXPERT.
FUSION GPS ALSO BEING SUED
FOR LIBEL IS ALSO TRYING TO
STILL VERIFY THE DOSSIER.
FORMER BRITISH SPY
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, HE HAS
LOST IN A HUGE LEGAL BATTLE.
HIS LAWYERS ARE REPORTEDLY,
THEY ARE TRYING TO CONFIRM
WHAT HE WROTE IN HIS OWN
DOSSIER.
HIS OWN FAKE DOSSIER.
VERIFYING THE DOSSIER IS
WHAT BUZZFEED, FUSION GPS
STEELE SHOULD HAVE ACTUALLY
DONE IN THE FIRST PLACE, NOT
TO MANIPULATE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE JUST A COUPLE OF
MONTHS BEFORE THE ELECTION.
THEY NEVER BOTHERED TO
VERIFY IT BECAUSE TO THEM IT
DIDN'T MATTER.
IT WAS ALWAYS ABOUT
SMEARING.
THEN CANDIDATE NOW PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP.
NOW, FINALLY TONIGHT, A
MAJOR REPORT FROM THE DAILY
CALLER, THIS IS INTERESTING.
AND WE ARE GOING TO FOLLOW
THIS VERY, VERY CLOSELY AS
IT RELATES TO JAMES COMEY'S
VERY QUESTIONABLE LEADERSHIP
AT THE FBI.
AND THE DAILY CALLER IS
REPORTING, QUOTE:  THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S
ENEMIER GENERAL SANCTIONED
AT LEAST 14 FBI AGENTS AND
OFFICIALS FOR A RANGE OF
IMPROPER SEXUAL ACTS SINCE
2014.
AND MOST OF THE CONDUCT, YES
IT OCCURRED DURING FORMER
FBI DIRECTOR'S TERM.
AND HERE'S WHAT'S MOST
TROUBLING.
THE DAILY CALLER REPORTS
THAT THE DOJ INSPECTOR
GENERAL, WE'RE WAITING ANY
DAY NOW, MICHAEL HOROWITZ
FOUND THAT COMEY ACTUALLY
ATTEMPTED TO INTERFERE WITH
THE INVESTIGATION.
WE REACHED OUT TO JAMES
COMEY FOR COMMENT,
SHOCKINGLY, HE NEVER GOT
BACK TO US.
I BET HE IS PROBABLY
WATCHING.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER EXAMPLE
OF HOW CORRUPT JAMES COMEY
REALLY IS.
HE IS A NATIONAL
EMBARRASSMENT.
HE IS A DISGRACE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
HE DESERVED TO BE FIRED.
AND WE WILL FOLLOW THIS
CLOSELY.
I CAN'T WAIT FOR THIS BOOK
TO COME OUT.